[Musique]
brassera m'écouter même pas concevoir
vous dira sera le calme marca le
coiffeur dar k j'adore ce qui me peine
comme ça j'adore ça c'est mon truc le
coiffeur tracera ne sais même pas
comment ça fonctionne mais vous allez
m'expliquer la téléréalité céda sera ça
dépend des épisodes ça dépend des fois
les hanches a peut être parfait d'autres
peuvent être bien voilà ça dépend je
n'ai pas de réflexion globale là dessus
d'accord larcat total je regarde tous
les matchs depuis tout petit par un
match de coupe du monde je ne manque
tous les matchs à tous les horaires
d'arca total jeu l'adorent
le seul point d accord c benzema j'adore
la brique au zaman abricotiers dans mon
jardin je guettais les abricots et je
les prenais 1 1 quand ils étaient mûres
d'arcade total l'abricot à l'om c'est
quand même une dar k comme le psg je
suis né à saint germain en laye j'ai été
élevé au foot au stade vélodrome de
marseille donc d'arca calme c'est une
race sera total sa le capcom par le
calme est ce que j'ai l'air calme le
calme c'est une race rap être calmes
c'est ne pas vivre c'est somnoler
brassera